let's start to take in this question and
the first thing i'm going to point out
is
let's contrast this to the first example
we did last time
when we had a look at simple harmonic
motion in the first instance i handed
you an equation
i said there's some object and it's
moving according to and then it was like
x equals and then you had everything in
the equation right something like
i'm trying to remember here 2 sine pi on
2 t
plus pi on 6 plus 3 minus 3
something like that right so you got
hint of the equation and then you could
literally
read out everything that you needed
amplitude center of motion
everything that you wanted to know was
just there in the equation as long as
you knew where to look
this is the reverse of that situation
right you aren't handed
an equation you've got to come up with
an equation yourself
off the basis of all of this information
so we're trying to reverse engineer
what's going on
have a think about this in fact what
we'll do is we'll write them down
together tell me what are the
salient details the important numbers
that you need
to take note of what's the first number
that you see which we need to include
in our equation the period what's the
period
pi on three seconds so if you haven't by
the way
jot this down all with me maybe up the
top you maybe you've progressed past
this and that's fine
but i want us to actually have this in
an important spot separately
pi on three seconds
so we've got a period we also have a
unit of time that's handy okay what else
you got for me
just read it off say it again
position what can you tell me about
position
okay so i have a position i'm just gonna
leave a space here for a second
i've got a position of x equals
three centimeters is a three centimeters
above
yes right so i also know from this right
what have i got
i've got not only a value i've also got
units and i also now also have a
dimension of motion
right i mentioned before uh when we
first talked about symphony motion you
can have say
left right uh in this case we've got up
down right so
the question defines that for us now
i've left this off here
because if you have a look carefully at
the question it says how does it
introduce this position
it says at a certain time
is there anything else like as you
continue reading is there anything else
that gives you a hook that decides when
that time is
okay so there's a velocity here right at
the same
instant right and it is moving
before i get to write that down right
does that tell us anything about like
when's the time of day or is there some
kind of i have to let t
equal something other do you see any
other clues there's nothing right so
what that actually indicates for us
is i can kind of decide what that will
be right
what do you think is like a convenient
easy to you know substitute value in
for the at a certain moment what would
you call that
let's call it time zero right so that's
a decision that we've made
so i'm actually gonna put that in a
different color i'm gonna say
t equals zero this is my
certain i think they sell a certain
moment is that right
this is my certain moment so they
haven't defined it
so why did okay all right and then let's
just come back to anger you suggested a
velocity
right so at this same certain moment i
have a velocity
v equals now at this point we've so far
just been like writing down numbers
pretty much as
stated but at this point you actually
have to think carefully
because there's a minor modification we
need to make based on the numbers that
are provided here
um to what we're actually going to jot
down here
you suggested velocity velocity is
actually not the word that's provided in
the question what question
what do they provide speed what's the
difference in speed and velocity again
speed doesn't have direction we actually
already have language of this all the
way back from accenture one and
extension two
when you have a quantity that includes
direction
we call that a vector
right when you have a quantity that
doesn't include direction we call that a
scalar right which by the way it's a
complete coincidence
that v for velocity and vector s for
speed and scalar but that's always the
way that i remembered it
now i could write and i will in a second
a 24 over here
but look again at the question and what
it tells us about the
direction of the velocity
the speed doesn't tell us but there's
another word that does
what's the word that tells us about
direction here
moving towards the center of motion
towards the center of motion now it says
three centimeters above the center of
motion i actually kind of sneakily said
x
equals three here that gives us another
thing just like i wrote in blue here
that tells us about the center of motion
they didn't specify it
i kind of have implied it where is my
center of motion
if at this certain moment i'm at x
equals three
say it again it's definitely gonna be
below
but i can say more than it's below it's
exactly gonna be
x equals zero right because if this is
three centimeters above then
x equals three makes the center of
motion at x equals zero does that make
sense
i could have just as easily said
arbitrarily because they didn't say so
let's suppose the center of motion was x
equals one
then at that certain moment i wouldn't
be at x equals three i'd be at x
equals four three centimeters above it
right
but i've actually implied this as the
center of motion
right so i'm just highlighting for you
excuse me
we make certain decisions
based on what you see uh based on what's
defined for you and what's not defined
for you
and we make them easy for us right uh we
could have had the central motion
elsewhere but
why not include a constant of 0 because
it's easier to work with
all right now just finally coming back
you said this is toward the center of
motion
right so if you're currently above then
which direction is
back towards the center it's down right
so if i'm writing velocity here
that's got to be minus does that make
sense that has to be negative
and because i've included units
everywhere else here as well
my velocity is going to be in
centimeters
per second okay
let's take stock again have a look at
the question have i captured everything
that the question has told me
look okay to you have i got all the data
have i missed anything
what do you recommend are you like it
tells you
okay good this will be this will be our
next step okay so i'm gonna go
and write down part a i haven't actually
done anything yet i've just
like taken stock of the situation but i
thought i hope you realize
how important this pre-thinking is it's
often the case in a question right
so we know it's simple harmonic motion
okay so i could
write a couple of things here right i
could write a differential equation i
could say
well i'll just write it down x double
dot
equals negative
n squared x now just remember right i
actually can write
x and not just x minus c because i've
already specified a center of motion
and if i say it can be at the origin
then i can use my like simple simple
nice version
simple version of simple harmonic motion
right the most basic form so i can write
that down
have a look at what question part a is
asking us to do it says
determine the equation of motion so not
the differential equation
now we have at least two choices i
actually have more than two choices but
to keep it simple i've got two choices
for what
can satisfy this and they're both on the
reference sheet do you remember them
what are our sort of basic two choices
of course yeah cause and signs some of
you have already looked into the
further into the exercise i've noticed
actually if you wanted you could put
sine plus cos
in here some version of that it would
still satisfy this differential equation
but we don't like we're deciding this
equation of motion so let's keep it
simple okay
now you really truly can choose either
sign
or cos here and in fact later on i'm
going to show you what happens when you
choose
a less helpful version you'll see why
it's less helpful in this instance
here i'm going to decide and i'll um
i'll leave it as a thing for you to
think about in the next six or seven
minutes right why i chosen this
particular version between sine
and cos i'm going to go with cos
now why would i decide cos think about
this right have a think about everything
like i've made this decision on the
basis of all of this information right
you don't have to do it um i will show
you what happens when sign
occurs here and how the question changes
right but we're all still going to get
the same answers because
it still satisfies the differential
equation it's going to work fine okay
let's try and feed into this right do i
know what the amplitude is
of motion in this information here do i
know
now it's a classic error to say yes i do
know
because look i've got this displacement
here like i think maybe i can go up
three and i can go down three tell me
why this is actually not
the amplitude of motion can someone
suggest to me why actually i don't have
enough information
to tell me that what do you reckon jack
it's not
we do not know if it's a maximum yeah uh
we call these the extremities of motion
do you remember in that uh
question we did on tuesday one of the
questions was out of a particular
equation tell me where the extremities
are
and if you know what this is then you
can say where the extremities are but
you haven't been told that that's
extremely so i can't reverse engineer
that right
i know i'm at that point but i don't
know if that's actually
an extreme right there's another actual
piece of information that tells me that
can't be an extreme
have a look back at what we've just
written it down right what are you
thinking joey
velocity think about this for a moment
right let's uh draw
draw for me over on the somewhere on the
side here right draw for me a quick and
dirty
uh cosine graph like so because that's
the one that i've chosen right
if you're at an extreme of motion so
i've got i've got three
on this particular graph here's one and
here are the other two
right think to your knowledge of
differential calculus what can you tell
me about the velocity
at any of those extremes of motion
should be zero right because you take
the derivative these are these are
turning points there more importantly
they're stationary points right so that
literally means at these exact moments
your velocity has to be
zero so that tells you not just oh maybe
this isn't like it can't be an extreme
of motion
okay so therefore i'm going to have to
park this i can't find a
just yet that gives me two other choices
right
n and alpha which is a more sensible one
to go for
first and why n what does n tell us
it tells us about period doesn't and i
actually know definite is the first
thing i wrote down
i know what the period is it's pi on
3. so how would you write this i assume
several of you already got the answer
but i need some working here right so
what am i going to write
that helps me get to a value of n
what do you reckon okay so i can say
this thing here the plan 3 is 2
pi over n that's how i calculate period
right
but that's a known value it's pi on 3.
i think it'd be nice if i actually said
what i'm doing here
so i'm sort of invoking my knowledge of
the period and then i write this
equation okay
uh looks to me like well what are you
going to get for n out of this
because your pies cancel right and then
you can flip this over to multiply by
two
off you go okay so that's good that's
handy i've got this now
x equals a cos six t
plus alpha okay so then at this moment
you pause and you think how can i go
from here
to work out a or alpha has anyone got a
suggestion
about what i could do next
okay joey where you going to start okay
i can find a derivative for this right
i've got an
x and i can get an x dot
now just before i go on and do this
right it is not immediately obvious to
go and
differentiate at this point because i'm
like but i still have like unknown stuff
right why differentiate now
can someone tell me why it's actually
useful to get not just a displacement
function
but a velocity function what does it
allow us to do yeah
uh it gives us the velocity at x equals
three
okay so see these two piece of
information that i jotted down here
right i can talk about this one when t
equals zero
but i can't yet talk about this one
because i didn't have
well i still don't have a velocity
equation okay the reason why this is
going to be useful for me is
i'm trying to find out what these
unknowns are right i need more equations
to be able to use them and i want to
access this data make sense